the Seven Nation African Peace
initiative led by South Africa's
president Cyril ramaphosa and Senegal's
president Maki Sal arrived in Ukraine by
train from neighboring Poland a journey
now customary for visiting dignitaries
less ordinary was what happened next as
the delegation was being shown Mass
graves in the city of butcher west of
Kiev a short distance away in the
capital itself an air raid alert sounded
followed by loud explosions of air
defenses as the Ukrainian Air Force says
12 Russian cruise missiles were shot out
of the sky this was damage caused by
Falling debris north of Kiev
it's believed to be the first time a
missile attack has targeted the capital
and it surrounds while world leaders
have been visiting
it is also the first time that any peace
initiative has been brought before the
leaders of both countries following
talks with President zielinski the
delegation heads to Russia to meet
President Vladimir Putin we are here to
listen
to listen both
to president zielinski and tomorrow
we'll be listening to President Putin
and we do so with deep respect
for the people of Ukraine which we have
expressed to president zielinski
but also in recognition
of the proposals that they have put
forward as a peace formula
the African leaders called for
confidence building measures like
prisoner swaps and the free movement of
grains and fertilizer exports as a
Prelude to more concrete steps such as
de-escalation on both sides and respect
for Sovereign borders but president
zielinski sounded less enthusiastic
demanding nothing less than a complete
Russian withdrawal
Russia is the only source of War and the
only reason why the consequences of this
war are causing damage to the whole
world to different nations on different
continents nobody can feel their borders
are protected or the safety of their
people is insured so long as Russia is
attempting to make their regression and
the Abduction of our people something
that is normal surely the withdrawal of
Russian forces from a Ukraine is the
only thing that can stop this war
it's a position from which zelenski has
never wavered for that reason the fact
that a complete Russian withdrawal from
Ukraine isn't explicitly part of this
initiative leaves open the question of
just how much support they can claim
they've actually got from Ukraine when
these African leaders put their plan to
President Putin in Saint Petersburg on
Saturday Jonah Al Jazeera Kiev